what's up y'all usually I don't do it
rolls to the episodes but then I
remembered I got a bunch of turn dates
and we need people there this is a
business September 14th
I'll be Camden New Jersey with Miss
Lauren Hill and nice I'll be in Bristol
Virginia with Miss Lauren Hill and
knives and I'll be in Wilmington
Delaware it'll be me DJ Tony trim and
who knows who else
Lauryn Hill and Nas won't be there
there's a bunch of other dates Miami San
Diego LA Bay Area C Atta Columbia
Missouri check them all out at Hannibal
Burress dot-com share the episodes in
Arlen whatever you know check out follow
Tony
shrim at Tony trim that and I'm excited
for you to hate his episode it's with
Leon Rogers outstanding comedian from
Chicago who I came up watching and
studying when I was you know he's
running a lot of great rooms in Chicago
and was always coming through fresh
materials so he was great to watch an
outstanding comedian and it's currently
on WGCI
6:00 a.m. to 10:00 a.m. 1:07 5:00 Monday
through Friday I've been through that
before as a guest and it's a tough trip
to make man that's early downtown
Chicago that early whoo
anyway this is a fun app we talk you
know old-school Chicago comedy tells
stories about Bernie Mac his DJ career
a little bit Otto too
a little bit so if I had a if we had a
program director for this they would say
you need to lay off the outer tool
welcome to the handsome Rambler podcast
I'm your host Hannibal Burres over there
on the drums
Tony trim we got special guest from the
shot on every morning 1:07 5w g zi Leon
Rogers
what up man what's happening man what's
happening man I can't call it man happy
to be alive beautiful loving life right
now in a good place man you know
sometimes in our profession in what we
do sometimes you get look that up and
stuff I'm actually in a good place right
now I can't complain it's been a good
stretch good man you know I was worried
not worried but you you are in every
morning yeah 6:00 to 10:00
yep and this is 11 ish now I was one I
was like you know with this first thing
I'm doing I'm yo leo gonna come in sharp
and fire man listen radioed is what I
tell all comments that want to do radio
you don't have the 30 minutes to screw
off cubicle time yeah you know you're a
regular job you can warm it in the break
room for 30 minutes you like hang
picking up no boxes didn't become to get
about 944 yeah I job Souza like going we
are sick I don't feel good
you know it's bright lights big city
because people ride to work on those
people time their day to us yeah if I
sound like crackling yeah they might
punch out or they don't want to tune in
so they want to hear me tripping so you
know rain sleet of snow you got go the
show starts at 6 a.m. at 6 but we do
show how to get the fire that's gonna
say you got a so you're waking up at
like 3:00 in the morning I leave out my
house about 3:45 that's crazy 15 you
don't even have a nightlight you know I
do though that's the crazy that's ok
it's not to stay awake he goes to the
comedy show tonight and [ __ ] I'll get
home I'll lay down at about 12:30 1:00
my alarm will go off about 3:15 3:20
wakes up at 3:15 I get up that's a bunch
of coke I hear ya so now the cool thing
is though so like when I leave you guys
I got a little thing to do like for
MetroPCS shoutout to MetroPCS and then
i'm done to the comedy show later on the
night yeah thirty nine o'clock so I'll
probably sleep catch catnap you know do
the over-40 nap thing but you don't like
literally I have to say leave me the
[ __ ] alone go away I tell my four yo
that'd be the scram there's nothing in
your day that matches up with my
somebody put that coat on your hook [ __ ]
out yeah that's Gaza man that's crazy
for 15 years fizzy it's been 14 years
Wow although cause you were on power 92
years and then I crossed over and went
to went from you know went went to d1
school you know I don't know if we
talked about this or you but it was the
funniest thing when chance the rapper
made the angels track
and they and they on his version of the
original version says GC yeah 107 92 92
baby - baby thought you and so I
listened to it like that abundance and
then I happen to be listening to one of
the stations in the car or you happen to
be on an uber or something and I was
like getting high for that part and it
was this 107 107 5 107 without the 92.3
every bro is real it's real it's like
dominoes and pizza like it's real like I
know you didn't like the thing about
that is though like I have a lot of
friends that still work oh sure and I'm
not never been one to do the whole I'm
on this station so let me take shots at
them and even though I've had some of my
quote-unquote friends that work over
there take shots because I want you shot
at the end of the day these are jobs
right and when that when when you get
called in that office that day cuz it's
gonna happen and they say hey you know
thanks been good run but we're gonna put
this 19 year old kid in your spot right
now yeah then what you know I'm saying
like I'm gonna burn them Brittany I'm
not gonna forsake people that I care
about and as a human being for the sake
of coz I wear the colors of this station
I do I represent my station everywhere I
go absolutely you know WGCI always they
wouldn't know wouldn't number one
station with a bigger station with a
heritage station but I think that I mean
I don't respect shaggy I don't mean I
respect Ferris was a good friend of my
you
J Allen the people that work over on the
other side but it is what it is Ang's
yeah you know stronger reception further
[Laughter]
92 it starts getting fuzzy you get out
[Laughter]
owned by one guy Crawford broadcasting
where's you know you know I heart media
owns WGCI they also own you know what a
breakfast club broadcasts you know kids
I don't know your you know so you got
power in LA yeah we're big boy on the
station so I mean like I said this it's
like Northern Illinois and Michigan
football yeah yeah d1 but so yeah our
heart is part of that's a machine where
if the well you know they have the
artist that they're like they're gonna
absolutely push through absolutely yeah
absolutely so I mean but acting today
it's a job it's a job man and something
I enjoy doing a lot of people can't say
that you enjoyed getting up and going to
work every day I do I actually love it
you know I'm saying there's a 30 45 yeah
bro listen I don't even imagine that
lifestyle Tony only time I regret it is
like so say like um Thursday nights I do
this thing at Chili's where we do
old-school hip-hop
yeah and I spend a lot of times I'm the
last DJ yeah so I week it out at like
1:30 to so I just stay up yeah go to
sleep if I go to sleep it's alright
right but I make sure that Friday I
don't have nothing planned for when I
get off work so that way I can come home
and not about she just doing the
graveyard shift 5 to 6 hours a day
I might get fantasies about my age I
probably should be getting 8 to 10 but
you used to you because I was looking at
your schedule doing my research I'm a
professional
I saw you hosting an album release party
tomorrow
they're living there and doing a comedy
show out there Harvey
they're leaving they're go doing a DJ
thing and then you know just stay up go
to work get off sleep half a Friday at
wind then probably around about 8:30 9
o'clock get up and so you drink a lot of
coffee or you're on the adderall know
what I mean are you just natural my
guilty pleasure is bro and I gotta stop
cuz it's not good for me kickstart yeah
now new case time and I have to catch
myself I used to be at like three or
four toes joints a day
wait what's kickstart Mountain Dew
kickstart they're like this but it's
like they got some very exquisite
flavors the pineapple mango and the
raspberry citrus are you just [ __ ]
energy I used to pop them like three or
four day and then I just was feeling
like [ __ ] like and I go you know man my
doctor was like hey man well you need
getting some rest let's say I get about
five or six today say I say we said well
what do you do to stay up I said what
drink you know energy things he's like
stop that like you know cool so now I'm
down to like one I curb myself to like
one and I just drink a lot of water but
I mean like I say I see how somebody who
has to remember scripts or summons got a
busy schedule will do a line of blow and
knock it out I put it underneath the
tongue or something maybe I'd get a
couple of things back clean up but then
they do the read the line reading let's
take it one more time but a little bit
slowed down a little bit they do it all
the [ __ ] time where's my sandwich and
if you did it to your mouth you make
your mom yeah so I get into the raids
bang
yeah but I do see how celebrities
probably do cocaine
just like just to stay up cuz I can't do
coffee I'm not a coffee guy never had
coffee in my life it looks disgusting
my mother drinks her coffee like
straight black like and I'm like yeah
great that looks like you drink your oil
coffee different people didn't want to
[ __ ] in the morning right away
really that's it didn't make you [ __ ]
right away well I got an auntie some
cooking you can eat better get that done
yeah real quick
she just got consistent consistent
diarrhea food we banned her from a green
bean casserole at Thanksgiving Day oh
she's not gonna hear this one my surname
on Dora because he's not going yeah
doors not in this loop she's like 60
plus the worst it's like I wish to think
she was cooking in like unclean dishes
cuz everything she could how many years
did it take before y'all said y'all Dora
my mother was my dad's sister rest in
peace he was just like after about two
or three times he was like a chill on
that well you all need you to bring
nothing you bring yourself oh that hurt
women especially older women put a lot
of pride instead of cooking yeah so
she's you know so like a dessert so I
don't know what it is is like you just
be like it did digits eviscerates your
bowels it's instant like with the night
hour yeah oh man yeah and you know yeah
my crib only got two bathrooms so once -
I'm tired up like the kids like my doors
red velvet cake
[Music]
explode her she's close Hershey squirts
Hershey squirts make it hurt the box
okay simple brows make it her colon
cleans : cleans didn't want : clean that
[ __ ] is amazing I just I'm screaming out
over to my recent holiday I don't know
if it was Thanksgiving or Christmas or
my sister's house in Phoenix and I had
so I just had to keep going to the
bathroom and it was it was a I can't
believe whatever I ate this diarrhea is
taking time away from my family
yeah my topic is you'd like at my job
like you know like I kind of like you
have to go under the stars our bathrooms
are wonderful
I heard me there's a shoe beautiful
well-kept maintained soft ambient light
early in the morning imagine if you saw
a dirty bathroom at 6:45 you heard a
freak out whooping like you know it's
like the dimension the light light is
key god it's just light enough for you
to read a magazine but don't not
over-bright you know I'm saying but what
I'm happy even my like don't get in the
stall like right next to me yeah if
you're if you're a runner or like
you know that [ __ ] disturbs me cuz I'm
here concentrating I'm just you know I'm
doing I'm doing the slow I'm doing the
Tastee Freez calm you know I mean it's
it's steady you saying you know yeah a
steady Tastee Freez kona you're coming
to the next one and you're like you
sound like a full-blown Chevy
you know Tastee Freez experience cuz I'm
one continuous stream yeah I'm building
the cone yeah Spectre mad every time you
do that you know that I don't know you
remembered a spectrum and it's now oh my
god you know 46 yeah so respect a man
like white meat put you tune in next
week for Spectre man I used to call to
gotta make him change overlord request
permission to transform do they go
mission denied spectrum and your power
cells are not fully charged I did he
would just go back to his regular job
[Laughter]
[Music]
you fight him on you to to likes okay
Jayant robot gamma all that is part of
that whole phenomenon I grew up watching
this stuff I like the idea of just a
practical superhero always like no you
can't right now
straight [ __ ] like the monsters
tearing up the city but because he had
fought some other dudes earlier he's not
like fully healed his name was George
that was the name of his alias he was
George and he worked for this like
environmental company and he would go
outside he was like
I can't let the monster destroy Tokyo
overlord request permission for
transformation permission denied Spectre
man your power cells are not at full
capacity how you are there I'm waiting
overload not yet Spectre man it is too
soon after your battle with giorious
creature you need time to recharge your
enemies you must wait request denied
I just stand by a little tidal wave
watch over our city is that it yes like
my type of [ __ ] no I want to see his and
then they will just the rest of episodes
this be him in his regular job Italy
charged up and then like they will piss
you off because then at the end they let
him transform and then they show him
about to fight the monster but didn't be
like tune in tomorrow to see him spectra
man beats mega da da da inspector man
top-notch cliffhangers right you've
never heard of it the lead villain was a
guy named dr. Gorrie
he was a 8 with like silver hair I used
to talk with his hand he's like I must
destroy the earth this is from the
states
not is from Japan man like a nice thing
okay but it buddy showed it on channel
44 like it came out right before Voltron
and [ __ ] like it used to be that Voltron
and battle of the planets which was
known as g-force yeah Godzilla era in
that same genre good stuff man
yo I was looking and I was looking at
this link you post it up and it pissed
me off too well sometimes you see these
prank videos where they what a print is
not really a prank is just some dumb
[ __ ] where's not really thought out a
prank is where kind of both people can
enjoy it but thus it may be doing be
somebody be mad about forever yeah like
a prank is but prank is
you know hey uh we put a whoopee cushion
and every time Hannibal says the word
and we're gonna hit it and make the fart
sound yeah that's a print
put in a standing next to me in a black
suit and saying oh I see the target take
the shot and then when I look down
there's a dot on my chest yeah that
somebody's playing with a laser pointer
that's a good way to get killed
especially out here like what everything
that's going on I was like that shit's
insane yeah I was walking up to people
he was like yeah I'm standing here
suspect has on a black shirt with red
logo
take the shot I've been compromised take
the shot in the guy everyone's away and
then I was waiting for one of the people
to be like this is [ __ ] no I was
waiting for somebody you think it's a
gun and just start busting whatever they
thought the dot was coming from yeah I
know some of those are fake but some of
them is I seen one was hey we're gonna
run up to people and say what's up and
asked to use their cell phone they were
gonna run away what they vote but no
that's that's death oh yes that kik-kik
getting his ass kicked though yeah no I
just saw one recently a guy goes into
this like pizza place it's in the hood
first of all his black guy runs a piece
of place and he's yelling at somebody
from behind behind the window and
they're like get out of here he's like
no I wanna get out of here
you can't leave me I won't let it go
down like this so yeah as a gas can
right
but the gas can is full of water but
people don't know that he's like I don't
know what I do without you and he starts
pouring the contents that a gas can on
him like his gas and he's about to let
itself on fire
so everybody starts running out people
grabbing kids there's one guy in the
blue sweatshirt calmly pulls out the
biggest Desert Eagle I've ever seen in
my life they say man don't play nice in
dudes like no no it's a prank look it's
water look look he was like oh now now
when when man man bout to blow your
brains out man man was like [ __ ] all
that give me more pieces
[Laughter]
yeah I don't get it bad I don't get the
whole I never got planking I never got
none of that crap
like just going and laying across
something I never got you know none of
that stupid [ __ ] I need any prank
involving [ __ ] or piss is not cool I'm
straight on bodily fluids
yeah I'm sure I'm good no funny way to
do that you know you know you status
show you've had a bunch of shows around
the city but one I remember specific is
the estate oh yeah gladiator gone that's
what comments came to die we who come to
die salute you because it was set up
like when you come in here at the stage
yeah the people here yeah there's one
VIP section over here but then you had
like a balcony yeah people set up there
and it was like the Roman Colosseum and
it would just get so nuts in the room I
would just come up on stage and be like
cuz I'm really fascinated by the whole
era and people used to come up and I
used to be like the crowd used to say
yeah and if not if you like you got boo
we just holler stoned him like yeah it
was the energy was amazing I missed that
room yesterday Mason used to be there
heckling my father know where it is to
get heckled by 6:9 NBA player is known
for beating up other big people like
three years in doing one thing I would
say about him rest in peace man if if
you got him with a good one yeah he
would chill cuz he is New York to the
hot seat try coming he was always a good
spirit dog like him he will [ __ ] with
you but when you got offstage he black
now you know I'm just messing with you
right but you'd be like no I'm not sure
cuz like you said six 990 500 smoke you
know the true story Anthony Mason you
should be this club called voyeur back
in the day and Mase we was out mace was
like honey shots of patron that's when
usher
patron popping but now the tequila
choices Avion tequila please drink
coffee on responsible so we have Meehan
Bianco I'll never forget a couple other
guys my cousin Darryl and honey shots
everybody's gonna do two in each you're
all saying is ten of us everybody gonna
do titties all right there's a twist
bro I say amazed uh my body is not built
to do over her continued shots of
anything not even ten healthy vitamin B
shots yeah salt grant wheatgrass none of
that no you won't do go I'll punch you
in your face yo so I got down the first
five and India I was like maybe I just
started looking at each other and
started throwing them over the back of
the shoulders like I remember wetting
his chick up yeah we don't die like
we're going to die but to him it was
nothing
yeah cuz there's a yeah he gives he gets
drunk he goes to one of the biggest
security guards in the club let's do six
five six six nice ass hey yo Shane you
know I got five grand in my pocket be
wind pocket put five grand hey hey take
it let's go outside and fight now we
could nah nah [ __ ] that yo the money
yours win or lose
let's go man he says he talking to the
he said fight him Oh thought he'd make
fight just go fight in general he wanna
fight he's paying on fire ground to
fight of them a hos fight a club so my
man like don't look at them son five g's
come on man four so
by trying to calm him down right I chose
to do this is a hang on life man if I
was you I tell him right this way sir
and soon as he goes out that side door
I need the a cave his head in with a
barstool or just close the door yeah
he's locked out he's like dodging makes
cool man
you know give him his money back I said
I'm not touching it you got the money
and I said don't come looking for it
right and I don't want to be the one
that has it so he got his money back
he's like you five g's with a lose ain't
nobody you can't go to a club and just
challenge the security also it wasn't
because of the Brooklyn Park huge bro
like I mean you you don't look real like
you don't realize we watch basketball
players on TV like and then you'd be
like okay even the little guys like
Chris Paul remember when I met Chris
Paul - right and that ain't gonna be
easy
yeah imagine Andy Mason or like guys
like Shaq I remember when I met him and
was standing at his navel yeah I mention
the first time when I did late it's
night show I found when I did stand-up
on and 2014 he was the guest on there
and I saw him in the hallway and I
that's I wanted to say what's up without
it that's too big of a person to speak
to I don't want to bother him he has
really giant people stuff to do I look
like a baby
standing next to me like I look like a
smear Marlon Mitchell Stannis and no
Marlon there's a pretty rotund guy you
know Marlon Mitchell Marla's got a
little weight to him he's
little mass little density but we look
like babies standing next to this dude
man and this is after MBA shack where he
loses a little bit of the weight and
starts living healthy yeah like imagine
when he was playing right 7 1 345 that's
insane
we were backstage once with Blake
Griffin and everybody was think he's
super cool but everyone
well yeah he purposely does the arm
around to make you look like an egg you
look like a dwarf every picture he's
like yeah cool come here
yeah I see stuff like that I think about
like Vince Wilfork who just retired
right from Houston Texas the defensive
tackle that's will for it right this
guy's was 6-3 tipping the scales at
about 3:45 yeah like what vaginas can
take that like that's a lotta that's a
lot of Train Cup even if even if the
lead engine is small the rest of the
train coming that's a lot of weight like
who lost that smoke like I wouldn't you
know hats out the females hats out the
females
combine that with the fact that he might
be ugly but just got a lot of money so
you're gonna take this you know say hats
out the females I couldn't do it I heard
from a reliable source that Scottie
Pippen once ruined somebody's internal
or Jesus Christ once again avatar you
looking at him like well Scotty skitty
but then you you see him in real life
you know yo man Scotty ain't skinny
don't I'm not starting a fight with no
NBA player that reach advantage
tell her the tape 60-inch reach at six
seven amazing cardiovascular right
insurance
she's never retirement though a still
healthier than you yeah too much good
stuff out here to be doing
fight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah shave your face with bevel because
this episode is brought to you by them
and its desired for coarse curly hair
and sensitive skin stepping up your
shave game is real simple just get the
get beveled cop slash Hannibal does getb
e ve l.com slash Hannibal and get them
good deals no razor bumps live smooth
get the full shave system and a
futuristic trimmer all of that all that
good stuff get to get bevel comm slash
Hannibal and get save save some money
look good stay trim
[Music]
you mentioned the you and Dion started
out around the same time no actually
Dion was Dion was on before me I came in
with guys like Marcus comb
yeah me Marcus combs we kind of came in
all around at the same time Frank
Townsend just to name a few
there's about 90 I started doing comedy
95 995 home from the military so I did I
did time in the military and that came
home when I was finishing out my reserve
obligation I started doing stand-up and
you know dealing them were a little bit
ahead of Dion Corey Holcomb Damian
Williams actually it was the first
person that would put me on stage so you
know I'm always indebted to him in Tony
Schofield was the second person to ever
bring me up on stage so these girls kind
of like my Big Brother's in the game and
always respect them even to the point
where this day if a promoter calls me to
do a show with them I feel funny about
them if they say well you know Damon's
gonna open for you I'll be like well now
let me host yeah like Damon go laughs or
let Damon host let me go like I just to
me it's a respect thing right I could
never see myself yeah you go out before
me there's one of the guys that put me
on yeah a lot of people used to be like
Oh would you skip no it's not that I'm
scared like this lots of [ __ ] that y'all
don't really learn about disrespect it's
like you DJ Tony so like if jazzy jeff
is the last DJ no Tony's a professional
he's not gonna go out and burn up all of
the hot [ __ ] yeah because it's 9 o'clock
you know at night and nobody's really
and as he was being addicted but it's
just as like an etiquette thing man and
I've learned that too and just translate
translate even over and when I DJ they
was like as I said because your
headliners gonna play all right
you know I I lubricated your vagina he's
gonna stab he's getting paid about
getting paid
yeah you gotta know you're opening your
opening role yeah the openers roll and
it's an ego thing it's a little bit of
bringing your ego down you know cuz you
want to turn up and be like yeah but you
can still rock the joint you can still
be a dope comic without going over your
time without stepping on everything that
the headline is doing or trying on some
new [ __ ] that's it yeah
what do you think a the big difference
is with you know if you're your era
coming up in the mid 90s versus you know
the new committee as you see right now
well unfortunately the internet social
media is a gift and a curse for new
comics it's a gift for the simple fact
that somebody like DC young fly could
turn a profitable career and using
Instagram to do 15-minute sketches or
whatever and then turn that into an
acting career whatever that's the pros
of it the kinds of it is that
everything's microwave everything's
microwave and nothing is there's no
creativity everybody's kind of doing the
same thing you're re-editing you know
you get it you get to sit up and edit it
and make sure it's perfect we're coming
out when we did we had rooms that man
listen it's like listening to a song
Tony you know before it gets to the hook
whether this [ __ ] is hot you got 30
seconds to impress me when I hear your
music your first 30 seconds you yell
yeah
you did and cut this [ __ ] off let's get
to it let's go back and we were coming
up comedy you went to Diane quarters
room at the click on a Saturday night
you could be ripping like dismantling
the [ __ ] room it's time they stopped
playing music upstairs yeah but you you
you had a thick skin that should happen
to some of these comics not they have a
fit you always like no dog you know
bombing is just something right now
that's a little bit better than you you
know I'm saying and we get it that's
that room and we had different rooms to
for me and you had to be funny you
didn't just get on because this person
knew you yet I tell people all the time
when jokes and notes was running Mary
they used to think Mary was like Mary
tough I said boy Mary is so nice and now
if you [ __ ] knew the time Nazi
we know the time Nazi y'all know Mary
we knew the time Nazi the time Nazi like
they get mad when she comes staring at
the stage when you going over your chest
and right and right at the stage that
ain't [ __ ] when she was the time Nazi
she used to get on the mic in the DJ
booth get the [ __ ] off the stage
oh sure and then everybody look back not
your [ __ ] yeah you did and people
start laughing at you Mary's Mike get
off my stage name you got out you didn't
work
you had the trial you had to audition to
do open mic on Wednesday nights at all
jokes aside any and everybody went up
and jokes and notes so it's just the I
think the bars been lowered a little bit
and and I think sometimes comedy gets
watered down everybody has a room that
didn't happen magnate everybody that
Navarone certain people out alone Damon
had this room George Willborn had this
one Corey Holcomb had these room but
these were all established killers now
God God has been doing comedy for two
weeks got a rule and you can't tell them
their day to [ __ ] cuz they got a room
because they uncle on the lounge and
this is my room and you know I'm dope
and I'm like you got five minutes and
three and a half of that [ __ ] don't work
but I mean I to their credit I think as
when you're in that brand new you if you
to examine you gotta have a room because
who else gonna put you up and [ __ ] but
see that and that's another thing like I
feel like I'll give you I give everybody
a shot workout rooms are just for that
not even explain that to the crowd when
I'm hosting this is an open mic night
you gonna get some good you're gonna get
some bad now what you don't want that is
is on a weekend at a comedy
yes well you want everybody get the meal
has to be perfect but this right here
these are these are sample chefs we
created samples and I tell the new
comments when they come up if you know
you got a solid joke do that [ __ ] and
get the [ __ ] out of here
instead of trying to fill the time
trying to fill the time I tell you three
or five minutes but doesn't mean you
have to use it all right you don't you
know I'm saying because you you know
five minutes goes by quick when you rip
it yeah it's the longest [ __ ] in the
world when you throw out a couple of
jokes and they don't work it's the worst
I had this comment what was that gig at
man this young cat I he he that's for a
guest spot on the gig it had been about
six months ago but then I had to move
because of something and then we
rescheduled the gig and I Nev it I
forgot about that guest by then he just
backstage and [ __ ] no like staring at
you yeah oh I get it and I said fine man
you can do you can do five whatever and
he did like 17 and I had to open and I
said what yeah hey what the [ __ ] as I
never again bro you won't ever and they
don't get it like they're like how can I
think I don't even get how you can do 17
off a five and they think you should
know it's like no man this is a show I
can't
I couldn't even I was trying to like how
can you I didn't get maybe doing an
eight seven four five five right but 17
of a five like where did you think you
were and where you written and where you
rip in that hole he was not ripping
English that was my estimated works yeah
it's like you know I say that all the
time like comics go out I said you're
not hurting me when I did college
college with a couple of comments they
were all knew I was the oldest gonna
show everybody that went out
hitting ripping whoa everybody's doing
over there time first cotton was
supposed to do chin he did 15-second
comic was supposed to be 15 he did 25
comedy came out after him was supposed
to do like 10 to 15 20 to 25 we got to
be out of the building at 11 I hit the
stage too 10:46 I was supposed to do 45
minutes but that promoter was sick he
still had to give me mine and I was
getting a nice little chunk of change
but I said I just pulled the dues
together I said man 1 all the [ __ ] y'all
did I went out and did one joke to erase
that and get the crowd was with me so if
you think he was going out there to make
me mom that's not gonna happen and - not
only did you cheat the people that came
to see me you cheated that promoter cuz
he didn't get his money's worth out of
me
but guess what I'll be back he's got a
car he's gonna bring me back but I bet
you y'all won't be back and y'all really
yeah God did y'all dang I said but was
it worth it like you gotta realize the
business is about relationships really
Bernie Mac told me that he's like man
80% of this [ __ ] is relationship 20% is
you're actually telling me is it because
I see a lot of bugs that come in here
that I don't think it's funny but they
good people I let him go up I say Wow
Bernie for real he's like yeah man said
but at the end of the day if you always
like you said if you being a dick who
wants to work with you and that's part
of being a dick if you if you just sit
this is my show bro but go ahead do five
yeah and you brought in 217 that's
blatant disrespect
I don't even respect anything that you
gave me this opportunity there's a
theater show I was like yeah it was it
was wild reckless where'd you meet
Bernie for the first time I'll see him
live the first time I ever met Bernie uh
I've started doing comedy I used to do
the Cotton Club Monday night he
originally used to hosted then he left
and Beyond hosted the
laughing they gave me the job and he
came through saw me do a show he said I
want you to come to my spot
Mill Chinese he had a spot called
milchin ears and this was what was that
there was downtown like nice like Swank
like downtown like in that
Fairbanks little section a nice man and
he was he doing movies at this point
yeah midnight Mac the show HBO okay
that's actually how that the the concept
for the midnight Mac show came from
milchin ears and what was crazy if I can
recall and Milton is you either got paid
$25 a drink a drink tab or a copy of
your show those were your three options
yeah here the video of videotape copy of
your show you can get a drink tab which
was $25 or you can get the $25 cash so
me you know being a new comic I wanted
to copy of my tape right get more work
yeah perform that and you wound up there
all you had to do was like five minutes
you went up there he used to tell you go
up there you do five minutes no more no
less and from Anna always used to just
talk to us he was cool always
approachable man that's what I loved
about him like I'm like damn I'm talking
to Bernie Mac right to him he was
economy right and and the greatest story
of Bernie ever for me
Damian Williams used to have a room
called TNT comedy hook out in Lansing
it's not Dixie kitchen okay no does he
do stuff there now somebody do some
night at Dixie kitchen is uh Tilly's
okay
Cory shout out to Cory Cory Bell she
does Tilly's it used to it's a little
bar restaurant off the channel Sundays I
recommend everybody to go check out this
beautiful spot we all standing in and
Sunday nights at TNT comedy hook because
that was the room to be I mean your new
comic use no delay eat good females up
there it was just crazy like new comics
syndrome so much bliss in here I got go
up yeah but we are all standing in there
talking gaming is getting the lineup
ready DJ dollar beyond the ones and twos
doing his thing Bernie Mac walks in
everybody just gets quiet and he was
like dangling one girl working on my set
for Kings of Comedy he was working on
his set for King County and he said I
want to go up first
mother is already all struck that Bernie
had just walked into Lansing but
generally from Chicago from the grid you
know I'm saying he move around he shoot
at chucks guns range all that we are
already all struck that Bernie Mac just
walk in but he's like I want to go first
Hanneman when I say he went up on that
stage and the whole [ __ ] you
tell that [ __ ] he was working on
that the milk oh I came to the house
other day man at 1:30 in the morning the
two year won't send the [ __ ]
downstairs for some milk and cookies I'm
going upstairs he coming down he gonna
walk bare to me like I'm a visible after
where you going
is it to get some healthy cookies
he said it's so fun I want to hear it
again I think it's a lot he says I'm an
Hancock I told myself man it's too
goddamn late for some damn cookie the
milkman take your old punk ass upstairs
and get some rest that's how I talk to
him [ __ ] that timeout [ __ ] I got
top-heavy bad ass kid he killed a kid
they don't kill me I'm gonna kill them I
can see you're reading jetting
everything right nighttime he tongue do
the same huh Bernie [ __ ] up though
damn kids I can't get no rest they walk
around the house Three Forks Hunger them
on got the finger in my nose hit if I'm
breathing all that counts it badass some
of my [ __ ] rockin all the goddamn
time no psychologist then Islamic mango
sit there she gonna go up stand the two
year were her tattoo you're safe where
the cook isn't you and he went up a beer
like 30 up top Funk Flex Bob Ross just
dismantled to join running throwing up
ladies having babies baby it was crazy
and then he goes he goes he goes yeah
yeah I like that I think I'm gonna keep
them and we all sitting up here like
Damon was like Leon you ground zero he
just dismantled this man but this is
when I kind of felt like an ember knee
like he literally had the pep talk son
of it the only way he didn't have to pep
talk was Cory Cory it was like [ __ ] I'm
ready let's go yeah so Dan was like I
Corps you go Cory wind ripped these like
Leon you ready I'm like I guess like I
mean I'm mind you I'm gonna ain't been
doing comedy that long and I'm sure like
I'm a regular that Sunday night people
loved him okay Bernie man and then Corey
Holcomb cable I met two totally
different styles of comedy where does my
little corn ball [ __ ] fit in like I'm
really sorry
just go up there and do you went up
there and boom hit and then Muhammad
went up but I was like one of the
coldest nights I've ever been on the
show that wasn't like an arena show that
[ __ ] was amazing man and Bernie was like
that's why I love Chicago we got some
talent out here he said I purposely came
and quit to [ __ ] show up I wanted
y'all to bomb Oh but Bernie was like he
tested like that he was the big brother
he's the big brother man you know yeah
when he got sick and he passed man it
hurt you know a big piece of Chicago
copyleft cuz he was one of the real ones
he's dope man yes sometimes you can get
intimidated when somebody go up and
rocket but this sometimes you just you
could just ride the wave or you could be
like [ __ ] that let's go yeah you can be
on some magic and bird [ __ ]
let's go Russell Westbrook Kevin the red
[ __ ] yeah it's sometimes out when I
haven't been at the Comedy Cellar for a
while and I'll pop in like I'm just dead
of really work on some stuff I ain't
even you know I'm just kind of and then
somebody going before me and they light
it up and I was like real chocolate this
might seem this might seem crazy if
people might condemn me for this but
there aren't three comedians that I have
my reservations about going behind cuz
they're just to me they're so [ __ ]
phenomenal they like they just they the
energy [ __ ] that they admit it's hard to
match was it one of them when he when he
does his show and don't [ __ ] around
Marla Mitchell like yeah Tom Kelly stuff
me myself personally if I have any
daughters I'm gonna catch a falling star
ain't gonna be no slicking people in the
basement having brothers looking like me
coming too though Tom oh hey miss
Mitchell we're lucky Cher
I'm gonna slip some hormone pills on my
daughter's food ride a baby so when they
get old and hair be real big like lean
muscular big old rock the not only head
no hair no teeth to talk just like their
daddy
dan why muscles bigger than you're
supposed to look like babe you look so
pretty come on get in the car
dan why we got big old legs and stuff I
do just naturally funny right somebody
that walks into a room and you just
thought giggling here's the [ __ ] way
he looks and then if he's born second is
Tony Roberts with new Tony Robbins is
gonna be a part of these rappers [ __ ]
the Dane about brilli well if I had
another song with Lil Wayne I'm a [ __ ]
face
[Music]
[Applause]
what kind of machine somebody put him
together like somebody took a bow
stuffed his face in a bowl of accidents
he's a genius though he keep rapping
about nothing and we bind it [ __ ]
and third Godfrey - I'm a man my friends
never believed I'm African I remember I
told my friends it was like a big shock
to them I say dude I'm Nigerian American
word we thought you like regular black
what the [ __ ] is rig
Crayola coming out with colors I don't
know about as I said so you caught my
parents house my father picks up the
phone you think you talked to the Lion
King
nice to meet the Godfrey go freezing out
here
Mufasa while still alive
who would be hit his Mufasa Godfrey is
on his silly [ __ ] yeah I'm cool I'm cool
when he gets to going all these
characters this [ __ ] or just doing silly
[ __ ] like I remember one day this dude
did an Instagram post and he said what
the [ __ ] is going on in starbursts
they got one banana on the plate look
they got a tag that says
and my kids were laughing and so on I'm
like damn like and then I tried to
combine and was like this crazy eyed
like gonna be like I'll say orange your
name is like funny [ __ ] yeah yeah how
you let's see if you can eat you have to
do ding cuz I'm not buying [ __ ] laughing
Godfrey the Godfrey gonna be your daddy
and then my wife comes out the back he
almost yeah they only put Godfrey on
last at the Comedy Cellar
he's only the years I've been doing a
Comedy Cellar you look at the lineup
he's never been in the middle ok when he
does the improv out in Schaumburg like
he comes on the radio yes it would I'll
say [ __ ] I got just got from Rhodes he's
always on and just hope my bosses ain't
listening him yet yeah and Tony Roberts
so much energy where you let but you
can't like I can't I can't tell you a
Tony Roberts joke he's one of the
funniest people in the world why is that
because it's just it's just energy and
before and just it's crazy yeah like
he'll be like just ah he just did that
it's like it's it it's this shit's crazy
cuz I saw he did the Knicks club in
Phoenix I did the Early Show he did the
The Late Show is I stuck around watched
his show I was talking with him oh okay
yeah did you watch the shows there what
yeah yeah I remember being like whoa
look at what he's doing with that chair
he's crazy
yes
[Laughter]
[Music]
like he said [ __ ] my performers are like
you ever been slapped so hard a [ __ ]
and he was like yeah and then they'll
sing a song like you got the breath of a
thousand acid yeah and then just come up
with some [ __ ] and start singing I'm
like it's [ __ ] amazing they slide
across like performance art yes so it's
like I don't
and each time I see him it's different
yeah oh so I'm just like this
[ __ ] insane bro I can't fight
like I would never even try I know y'all
got me back
nah bro yeah yeah I'll take less money I
think cuz that was just his energy is a
ball he's super saying like he's Dragon
Ball Z like he is like uh he go to
different levels with that [ __ ] I was
trying to ask where do you try out like
I would love to see him [ __ ] with this
oh I probably have a seizure laughs yeah
I probably wouldn't even use it they got
the same type of like energy
yeah but then Godfrey adds the African
stuff to it so it's just those are two
and like I say Marlon is just like when
Marlins not giving thanks to God yeah
cuz he annoys me I love Marlon you know
this is beautiful guy got us all here
yeah but when Marlon like gets into it
[ __ ] I wanna be funniest dudes I've
in my life yeah man shut out the Marlin
check out that you check out Frances
cocktail lounge yes sir every Monday
yeah just niching them doing a comedy up
there that's all 79 490 75th 75th sevens
on 75th Street yeah
in the shot do you it yeah man where'd
you start DJing this will be number
seven
you're number seven and actually what
was crazy about it I was just doing it
for fun because I just always watch DJ
dollar bill and the club in the comedy
club and I used to do this thing with
Peter Piper
we're on DMC I used to be like I just
thought that was so amazing and I
thought DJ's and comics are wanting to
say right in this aspect and stop me
stop me from you it's just you in the
booth it's just you on the stage you'll
open it how you get the people in when
you first start just set up you you play
you get the dancefloor cracking you got
everybody laughing tell the wrong Joe
lose the crowd they're wrong song they
disperse off the dancefloor and
sometimes it's hard to get them back
yeah well sometimes you can come back
when you rip it and kill it standing
over when you ripping and kill it
[ __ ] [ __ ] look up it's three
o'clock the club is closed and they like
oh no [ __ ] done oh you did yeah so
they're parallel in the fact that they
master ceremonies we control crowds what
of course I think the biggest difference
though is that a lot of times the
promoters of a club will purposely asked
you to play songs that have dispersed
the crowd so more [ __ ] go yes go
drink but play a song that'll dead this
crowd right now because [ __ ]
aren't buying drink right now but even
with that being said when you
that bad [ __ ] yeah get the [ __ ]
like rest in peace Timbuktu
I've seen promoters come to Tim and be
like man kind of slow it down yeah you
know - I used to be like do you want my
focus to be back in his business next
week man leave me the [ __ ] alone
yeah and all you just do the I can't
hear you okay yeah yeah I do
and it was just the opening myself I was
on a mic let's play all the songs
without closed with the mask off it was
something from Playboy cardi and it was
at Chris Brown Gucci Mane tone it down
they got it
and then that played mask off and then
this girl comes up into my right ear is
oh this song is so this song is so March
but it's dark I need to give her that I
just just that I just kept looking at
the laptop saying it
she said that [ __ ] about five times like
the muse is not even that loud you know
my phone's been doing to me lately when
I do that because I do that move all the
time this is what they do they pull it
up on the notes that is the most
annoying shoe I just have my cousin my
cousin Dave we're gonna sign I just have
him stand at the DJ exactly maybe like
what do you want he'd be like all right
what do you want I didn't know like what
gods would be like man y'all wanna
answer could he play he said so let me
get this straight you're a man and
you're gonna act another man and play
something females he be like you know
he'll say some credible [ __ ] to their
baby well I want my friend wanna hear yo
so what's what's going on y'all
messing with the DJ and security yeah
cuz that's how the [ __ ] gets play oh my
god but I don't get bothered yeah but um
watching dollar bill all the time and
dollar bill was like that'll be okay
with my house when there's all a
requisite [ __ ] that I had it
CDs like dude why don't you DJ I was
like I'm not a DJ bro I just love music
and being in the military help because
when I went abroad I met more people and
I know cuz living in the Midwest man we
didn't really have a style when it came
to hip-hop you know if you kind
understand what I'm saying you know the
East Coast yah Mobb Deep yeah wu-tang
yeah you had a sound Florida bass music
you know you had Ronnie oh and Joe Cool
2 Live Crew you know poison clan didn't
even when you win the Texas Scarface you
know you had ghetto boys then of course
the West Coast g-funk and all that stuff
in the Midwest we were kind of like in
the 90s we were floating we didn't
really have weird are like gangster [ __ ]
and we're now mind you once again that's
later we talking early early nineties we
did barely that's like Jenna was bitin
like Dodge effects
[Music]
can I borrow dollar album even with that
like you still talking it still had it
was Midwest but it had New York appeal
exactly okay so it was until late 90s
two thousand two twisters crucial
conflicts you know I listen to da smart
non limb guys but they weren't
nationally known artists very smart to
me to this day shout out to be a smart
if the other seaters may one of the
colas gangster songs ever in the history
of Chicago rap music's called walk with
me where he takes you on a that gives
you every game from the top to the
bottom I didn't know that's that's his
name walk with me
yes if you came in Chicago and didn't
know [ __ ] about our gangs that's 101 you
listen to that song and you'd be like
okay I'm not gonna go here and if I get
shot on the west side don't let them
take me to Loretta Hospital cuz I'm
gonna die cuz did he say that about that
we're gonna close it out on that yeah so
Mickey Halsted and all them guys you
know they they came a little bit later
so we didn't have an identity in Chicago
until you know the comments in the
Kanye's started coming along what you
could you know really see Chicago hip
hop so when I went abroad and just
started listening to everybody's music
cuz you know I was wu-tang mob
you know big nice that's all of rock him
to God I um does this all I do gangsta
you know but then when I went and I'm
like damn poison clan home team oh wow
you MCS yeah oh wow Houston oh wow the
west coast got hip-hop my father's
hieroglyphics
Sofia to saucy Nomad mister EE no mr.
Bob now Molina I'm like oh wow
[Music]
mr. da valina mr. Bob stop Alina mr. Bob
Alina wanna make me say no when I
thought West Coast all I thought was
gangbangers you know Snoop Dogg and all
that so he was like now you need to mix
dog you need to DJ and I was like he
said let me teach you he broke out the
twelves I used to go over his house in
Indiana when he lived at hammy and I
learned on 12 no cerrado nothing we
learned straight records you know and
then uh after he said man I want you to
come over here every day and just learn
how to beat juggle I said dollar bill if
we wasn't cool that sounded real gay
that sounded like oh I'm not like that
[Laughter]
that's very fortunate that you got to
learn off of vinyl oh yeah I feel like a
lot of these kids are missing out
controller on yeah it's just when you
learn on vinyl you have a different way
different appreciation of the music
itself and just the art of turntables
and mind you too
being in Chicago I come from house music
see when I was a teenager we went to
house parties a lot there wasn't no was
no hip-hop parties like that we were
going to house parties even a lot of
your DJ's today like a guy like v-dub
right who you here V DUP mixtape bully
you know he get your vest on but v-dub
was one of the dopest house DJs in
Chicago Farris Thomas same way they just
reinvented themselves you know Terry
hunter all that these guys were house
DJ's so with that background and
learning how to blend and of course step
it there's another thing you know the
stepper says you you learn how to blend
music so once I got that down I just
kept working and I started buying my own
equipment and I reached out to a lot of
DJ's who I respected and thought was
dope and some of them you know looked at
me like get the [ __ ] out of here
you're trying to capitalize on what we
do be a quote-unquote celebrity DJ well
when that never was my goal
I never wanted like I didn't never want
somebody like Tony to look at me and be
like oh he's a celebrity DJ I want
somebody like Tony be like yo that
[ __ ] could rock that set you
know I'm saying or he inspired me to go
pull some records out my crate that I
ain't been using in a while and I think
that was one of my advantages I didn't
come up
DJing from laptops yeah because now the
rites of passage to the next carry
around yeah and get your arms fall and
tear a rotator cuff or two literally
just take unload your car with crates of
Records like to rock a party and your
friends and your friends with you and
all that but but I will say this dough
just like I don't want to be the old man
on the line when it comes to comedy and
I can't be mad at comedians that use
Instagram and Facebook as a platform
because I think how hard a vis is
amazing yeah this should be a breeze
like that [ __ ] is funny but that's
because he can do that I can't be mad at
technology you need them because you
know it does save you a lot of work when
you can get 50,000 songs right there
that's that's you you can bring your
whole life traveling yeah absolutely
so even with the controllers it's all
that's a more about convenience now yeah
when you got people that's sinking and
and cheating and doing all that but they
don't respect the craft anyway and it's
gonna come out and let's be honest we
got to blame the audience sometimes even
with comedy Hannibal you can relate to
this you get somebody like Tony woods
who's brilliant writer right write
something so crazy and over-the-top
but the audience is so used to you yeah
much a nosebleed
hey it's microwave and we want those we
want the quick laughs we don't want to
sit and listen to your story and wait
for the punchline at the end we want it
now and like with DJ when I go to a club
if you sit and listen right
DJ's don't have to blend up do nice
blended all the crowd want is their
favorite song
play that's all they want and the end to
the fact that they don't care that if
you was just on and you played mask off
bo-tat yellow and bad and boozy and I
come back on and I play bodek yellow
mask off a battle you know don't give a
[ __ ] bro that you could straight you
could like legit be killing this happens
to be all the time killing the
dancefloor destroying it everybody
dancing my [ __ ] still got a request
yeah y-yeah do you have a request or
[ __ ] yourself yeah why aren't you
dancing with them it's a model fest
everybody wants to pose and then new
clothes they Balenciaga Hermes right and
everybody wants to stand and chill and
this is why I like I'm so glad now like
I try to create lands with parties like
for my birthday I did an indoor beach
party but it was all 90s teen you know
I'm saying so I said so if you're coming
here to hear the trap you're gonna be
upset right cuz we're not playing this
[ __ ] we're gonna have a good time
playing music from 1990s all the way
into mid 2000s and we gonna have a good
time it's like and I feel like a DJ's
job personally is to keep music alive I
feel like your job is to keep hot [ __ ]
alive and not just let it get lost
I blame blame partially actually I blame
a lot of like the Spotify streaming
generation because it's everything so
instant and then they give you the
what's hot now like you know you like
this yeah so like back in the days when
when I first started like I dug you know
what I'm saying like I'd have the go
places find shocking wax you over here
yeah exactly you know like gramophone I
had to I had to dig like now I don't
think it's just right there to touch
Google and then they tell you oh you
like playboy guarding there it's instant
I've no - you - three other time
like I one day I was DJing with this guy
and I was just looking at all his
equipment I was like
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] trash like you've
been dropping it or whatever and I was
like yo bro where you get your music
from because I'm listening to him
playing it sounds horrible oh man I'll
pull everything off YouTube that's crazy
but you know you're not in the record
pool you're not in like you know I mean
the $20 that you spend on that loud you
take that $20 a month I have access to
thousands of songs yeah I said I said
the lot of the DJ's don't even care
about the crap it's just like I want to
get into the club free
excuse my French [ __ ] a few [ __ ] off
this cuz we all know the DJ get stale
and that's it I want to live like that
like and then then you're disrespecting
the game that's another thing too I got
into it with a lot of promoters because
I knew my worth
you know saying oh yeah yeah we got this
party once you do is downtown we charge
a 50 to get in but we want you you know
can you spend from 9:00 to 12:00 you'd
be the first DJ for $150 it's good
exposure no [ __ ] my kids can't
eat exposure
I still get exposure offers oh it's
great exposure but you know tone I'm not
even mad at that man depending on what
it is hey man
Barack Obama's having a swingers party
he needs somebody to keep the mood right
ain't really no money in it okay some
other people there they throw swinger
parties also they go easy right you know
said so I'm gonna charge no mother for
the every Friday night that y'all do
with somebody's probably gonna get shot
afterwards in the parking lot no I can't
do that
Lee you know I'm saying if it's 300
people here y'all charging $20 at the
door you mean to tell me I can't get a
dollar off every year a dollar and
that's light work right but but DJ's but
they the rates in Chicago are [ __ ] up
and up but because the
the guys just wanna be the ones to say
that I DJ this part no they don't they
don't know that you are the party
you can literally but now was so [ __ ]
up about that is the promoter goes like
oh you're not gonna play well let me get
out my little exactly well you know what
there's two generations of these these
DJ's right now you got the guys that
that have the Spotify and they can just
stream whatever and just kind of play do
whatever it's at their fingertips and
then you got like the nerdy vinyl
collector like a name-calling dreidels
right but they just slam by like but
they're special because they play by I
know but they don't know the no man no
blend no no creative no creative
transitions it's just playing for Pb are
y'all like that
yeah the play for peanut not even that
it's not this one just like the dirt
just a nerdy link the eclectic
[ __ ] yeah like playing for PBR I
hear the crackle yeah yeah yeah the
audiophile nerd record Collette so I
mean you know I just try to be
respectful to craft that I'm in and I
look at it as a craft I look at it as
you know something that if you've been
doing it for 30 something years I don't
automatically assume that I could come
in and and bless it I worked hard like I
practiced for at least 225 years before
I even went outside well with it and
when I went outside I did a family
barbecue yeah and you know my father
kept it well honey he's like yeah stick
to the commo town you know yeah I
couldn't take him seriously because yep
yeah man
glad to have you on the show Lee I know
you got to get out of here man know what
I'm glad to be here man listen all right
Hannibal I want to tell you dog proud of
you man thank you from watched your
journey from from first time ever met
you southern Illinois yeah with my man
rje we was down that do a show yeah -
the fact that you doing what you're
doing now and you still come home
[ __ ] with the lab yeah you know like you
Dion you guys y'all still come on I live
out here I know because you keep your
make yourself scarce
ya know come back as like no y'all just
don't see him you know I dig the fact
that y'all coming you guys like you guys
like Deon Cole like Deon comes home and
is on 70 [ __ ] v yeah you know I'm
saying so that that's that's special man
DeRay all you guys I'm just proud of you
and know that uh my self-esteem doesn't
go down as make sure y'all follow me at
Leon Rogers on Instagram Twitter
Facebook it's my name don't put no D in
my last name I don't do the Diaz ro G er
[ __ ] that's like the guy that used to
come in and change sweaters the shoes
[Laughter]
that was blood man do that you committed
a crime he did this it was normal yeah
change [ __ ] you just scared
[Laughter]
alright thanks leo
put your left foot in front of your
right foot and walk with me through the
city a child where the pole just be have
you heard a city crime city with the
south side what you need to be teased
the black stones don't go outside
so let me be your tour guide so no jokes
and off the book side [ __ ] they know
that Costa and 49 mistake so mingle but
just a few goodness know you got beat on
a three finger
we call it the 53rd estate the MCS be
running the home police missions up in
the trailer
Xavier walk with me I'm here to remind
you that if your buggy need to know
exactly who to throw up besides up so
many a poly you might have about me come
and identify your body so often me
[Music]
peace
[Music]
body drop it off girl from train
terrific damn you know it looks good the
kind of man with me jiminy but see the
city
on the page for something you wanna know
about major crime areas in Chicago
almost anything you wanna know you can
talk to me but if you wanna walk with me
[Music]
let's take a trip to the west side what
people in lay up in telling me it's the
best side
some even say it's the fresh shot but
boss my conviction I can see the
realistic inside baby fussing [ __ ]
it's not science over 2,000 static where
that's a stop crime and every time I
pick it up he go to Mount Sinai
let me tell you in the hood well like it
can count with them doing up that you
live down
we even got new breeze on the show but
Oh 16 you must be gonna see them so they
be going what let's go see the same
buddy I've been doing awesome
so they forgot about the bases your back
was over on watch it now homie you
should be full of unknown like Chicago
Avenue now this letter for surgeon is
wrong you can custom if you wanna be
custom traveling by slow we'll be
waiting on you on California these eyes
full of hard brothers have you been to
sit you love us when you gesture
exceeding fools I think the shy is full
of bust you can trace the chalk to see
or you could be on the safe side [ __ ]
aint walk with me
there's no peace its women
strengths
[Music]
Oh mrs. Rossini madam
[Music]